WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THIS HEARING TO ORDER IS A
PLATE TWENTY TWENTY NINETEEN
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER
I WE'RE GOING TO OPERATE
FIRST AS A SUBCOMMITTEE IT
UNTIL WE CAN ACQUIRE A QUORUM
-- I SEE ONE AUTHOR OUT
THERE MISTER COOPER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO -- COME FORWARD
AB ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
PUT ON YOUR READY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB ONE TWENTY SIX MAKES
IMPROVEMENTS AND THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM TO MAKE
CLEAN VEHICLES MORE SENSIBLE
TO A GREATER NUMBER OF DRIVERS
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL INCREASES REBATE
LEVELS BY FIVE DOLLARS FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND LIMIT
ELIGIBILITY FOR HIGH INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THESE IMPROVEMENTS
TO SEE RP WERE ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED BUT MY BILL AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY FOUR AND ROLLED
MILLION DOCTOR TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH A
ONE YEAR SUNSET SB SIX FIFTEEN
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN CONTINUE
FERMENTATION OF THESE PROGRAM
PRUDENT FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY THESE IMPROVEMENTS
TO BOOST TO STATION LEVELS
FOR LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
EXPIRED THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR AB ONE TWENTY SIX
WILL CONTINUE THE CRP PROGRAM
CHANGE IMPROVEMENTS TO MEET THE
GOAL OF TEACHING MORE CORRECT
EXCUSE ME REACHING MORE LOCAL
INCOME COMMUNITIES BUT DO SEE
REBATE LEVELS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AB ONE TWENTY
SIX WILL MAKE THE VEHICLES
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS LIVING COMMUNITIES
WITH POOR AIR QUALITY
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
IN THE REPRESENTING PLEASE
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BILL
MCGAVIN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT
WE AS PART OF THE CHARGE HAD
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN HAVE BEEN
IN FAVOR OF EXPANDING ACCESS
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY
NOT HAD ACCESS TO THEM AND SO
WE'VE SUPPORTED THE BONUS REBATE
FOR LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
CONSUMERS WHICH HAS CONTINUED
IN EFFECT -- AND AND HELP
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
WE ALSO HAVE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
BEEN SUPPORTING AN INCOME CAP
ON THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT BECAUSE WE WANT THESE
FUNDS TO BE RESERVED FOR THOSE
WHO NEED THEM THE MOST AND THOSE
FOR WHOM THAT THE FUNDS REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN PROVIDING
AN INCENTIVE TO PURCHASE
THAT ELECTRIC VEHICLE SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR IS
USING THE NUMBERS FROM THE THE
PREVIOUS LAW -- WE HOPE THAT
THOSE LEVELS ARE RE EXAMINES
WHEN THE REPORT COMES IN FROM
THE A. R. B. AND THAT WE USE
THE MOST CURRENT DATA BECAUSE
IT'S ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT
THE INCOME CAP SHOULD BE
REDUCED SO THAT THIS PROJECT
CAN LIVE WITHIN ITS MEANS --
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THE REBATES WOULD
CERTAINLY RUN OUT IF NOT
FOR THE INCOME CAP SO IT IS
PROVIDING THAT JOB OF CONSERVING
THE RESOURCES DIRECTING THEM
TO THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST
AND SO WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
IF ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME NEW
REPRESENTING PLEASE HI CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDING
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
CLEANER NOW FOR NONPROFIT IN
THE VALLEY DEDICATED TRY TO
GET LOAN TO BE ABLE ACCESS
TO LARGE VEHICLES WHICH ON
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE
HELLO MY NAME IS MARINA
FRANCESCHI I'M UC DAVIS
STUDENT HERE WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
HI MY NAME IS THE NET MARTINEZ
-- FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO AND I'M HERE A
PROVISION IN CALPERS AND
-- -- -- I'M WITH THE BILL
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT HAVE -- WANT
TO SUPPORT THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS WE AUTHORS BILL
I'LL TAKE YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
MR COOPER WAS LIKE CLOSE YEAH
THIS FOR THE DRUGS VEHICLES
THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE REBATES DRIVE SOME
THE OLDEST CARS -- IN STATES
WILL DEFINITELY HELP THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER FOR
BRING YOUR BILL FOR TODAY --
HOWEVER AS THE TRANSPORTATION
CHAIR I NEED TO MAKE POLICY
DECISIONS A RECOMMENDATIONS
BASED ON THE BEST AVAILABLE
DATA IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE USE OUR STATE DOLLARS AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE FOR ANY
STATE CENTER PROGRAM AND THIS
IS WHAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS
FOR SO THAT WE DO UNFORTUNATELY
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT IN
YOUR LAST SEEN YOUR P. BILL
HAS NOT BEEN COMPLETED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD
MATTER FACT IT'S WAY OVERDUE
THIS IS VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
ME BECAUSE I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
LEGISLATIVE AND MAKE SURE THE
LEGISLATION IS MOVING FORWARD
THAT IS APPROPRIATE MY
SUGGESTION TO YOU IS TO
CURSE OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCE BOARD TO FINALIZE
THE REPORT AS MANDATED BY
LAW -- TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
DANCING THE BEST POLICY FOR
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE DON'T KNOW
AND -- MAYBE WE NEED TO FIND
SOMEBODY ELSE WHO CAN DO THESE
THINGS AN APPROPRIATE FASHION
WITH THAT COURAGE
YOU TO MOVE FORWARD AND GET THE
RIGHT INFORMATION AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND -- I'LL BE
SOMEWHERE YOUR BILL THANK YOU
MISTER ICE ONCE A ON A CLEAR
YOUR SENTIMENTS -- A ARBY'S
THESE THE THUNDER KNOWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP WITH THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION -- SOMETHING'S
WILL CHANGE BECAUSE THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
TAKING SOME AUTHORITY AWAY
-- STEPS ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SEVEN WE NEED ONE MORE
SO WAS IT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN -- WHEN WE GET A QUORUM
WILL TAKE A LOOK THANK YOU
MR MURATSUCHI WITH AB SEVEN
EXCUSE ME THREE SEVEN BUCK
THAT AB THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I AM HERE TO PRESENT TO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TO SIX
WE ARE PASSING OUT
TO SOME COPIES
OF THE NEXT BIG THING
AND MOBILE TECHNOLOGY
MOTORIZED CARING DEVICES
THESE ROBOTIC DEVICES ARE
DESIGNED TO FOLLOW BEHIND
A PERSON AS THEY WALK AND
ARE INTENDED TO CARRY HEAVY
LOADS UP TO FORTY FIVE POUNDS
THESE PERSONAL CARE IS WILL
PROVIDE PEOPLE WHAT THE
INCREASE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
MORE WALKING AND REDUCE CAR
TRIPS AND IT ESPECIALLY
IS GOING TO BE -- HELPFUL FOR
THE ELDERLY AND THE DISABLED
-- TO MAINTAIN -- TO BE
ABLE TO GET AROUND WITHOUT
HAVING CARRY UP TO FORTY FIVE
POUNDS -- IN IN --
LUGGAGE AS WE ALL KNOW
-- WE ARE COMMITTED TO
STRIVING TOWARD OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS
-- BY HELPING TAKE CARS
OFF OF OUR LOCAL ROADS ACCORDING
TO THE U. S. EPA CAR TRIPS OF
UNDER A MILE AND UP TO ABOUT
TEN BILLION MILES PER YEAR
SO THIS DEVICE AGAIN CAN GO A
LONG WAYS REDUCING MANY
OF THOSE -- SHORT CAR TRIPS
WHILE NOT ALL THE TRIPS --
CURLY TAKEN BY CARS ARE MADE
BECAUSE THERE'S A NEED FOR
STORAGE OR CARRYING HEAVY
-- LOAD SO WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS TICKET TECHNOLOGY THE
SHORT TRIPS TO THE STORE OTHER
LOCATIONS COULD BE REDUCED
I HAVE -- THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF PIAGGIO
FAST FORWARD -- MISTER GREG LYNN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS BILL CURRENTLY ENJOYS
A A STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE TECH
COMMUNITY WITH A NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI A
SIR PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND THE COMPANY'S NAME AGAIN
GREAT I'M GREGG LANHAM THE CEO
OF PADUA FAST FORWARD AND THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND VICE
CHAIRMAN FONG AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY SO WE WERE READY
TO LAUNCH JETER WHICH IS
OUR FIRST MOBILE CARRIER
PRODUCT IN ABOUT SIX MONTHS
IN ADDITION TO WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI SAID WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE COMMUNITIES
MORE CONNECTED WE'RE TRYING
TO GET PEOPLE TO HAVE THEIR
HEADS UP OFF SCREENS IN THEIR
HANDS FREE AND ENCOURAGE THEM
TO WALK TO RUN THESE SHORT
ERRANDS AROUND WHERE THEY LIVE
-- WERE TRYING TO MAKE HELP
PEOPLE BE MORE ACTIVE IN IN IN
PARTICULAR THAT GOES FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY VETERANS
WE'VE ALREADY DONE A LOT OF
PILOTS AND THERE'S A HUGE POLE
FROM THESE COMMUNITIES TO HELP
PEOPLE MAKE A CHOICE TO WALK NOT
NECESSARILY DR -- IT'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLE THAT SUSTAINABLE AND
AND WE FRANKLY FIND IT AN
UNFORTUNATE CHOICE WHEN CARRYING
A COUPLE GALLONS OF MILK OR
A COUPLE OF BAGS OF GROCERIES
YOU GO FOR YOUR CAR KEYS AND
USE A TWO TON VEHICLE TO DO
THAT WE THINK IT'S MUCH MORE
PRACTICAL TO DO THAT AS A
PEDESTRIAN WERE OF VERY HUMAN
CENTRIC COMPANY WERE NOT AN
AUTONOMOUS COMPANY WE HAVE
NO INTEREST IN AN AUTONOMY
WERE ACTUALLY PROGRAMMING
AND TRAINING OUR VEHICLES TO
UNDERSTAND THE WAY PEOPLE MOVE
AND TO MOVE THE WAY THEY MOVE
-- AND AS A HUMAN CENTRIC
COMPANY WE ARE VERY SAFE --
THE VEHICLE WEIGHS MUCH LESS
THAN A BICYCLE WITH THE PERSON
ON IT IT'S MUCH SMARTER THAN
A BICYCLE GOES MUCH SLOWER
-- WE THINK IT'S GONNA BE ONE
OF THE SAFEST THINGS ON THE
SIDEWALK -- AT IT
IS -- HAVING A A SENSOR
ARRAY THAT FOLLOWS PEOPLE
IT UNDERSTANDS WHAT A PERSON
IS AND HOW THEY MOVE AND --
STOPS IN CASE THERE'S ANY --
TRAFFIC OR CONFLICT AND
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA I
WOULD SAY IS ABSOLUTELY TOP OF
OUR LIST AND WHERE WE WANT TO
BE BECAUSE OF THE CLIMATE BUT
ALSO BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS SO
MANY CITIES AND TOWNS THAT HAVE
A VERY HIGH WALK ABILITY SCORE
WHERE PEOPLE CHOOSE TO LIVE
BECAUSE THEY CAN HAVE A WALKABLE
LIFESTYLE AND WE WANT TO HELP
THEM AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN THAT
WAY -- WE WANT TO BE COMPLIANT
WITH ANY -- LEGISLATION
AND BE PROACTIVE AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE -- WE WANT TO
TALK TO FIRST AND AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE LAWS WHICH SHOULD
NEVER CONTEMPLATED SOMETHING
LIKE CHEETAH OUR UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND VERY
THANKFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI IN HIS UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS TO TO BRING THIS BILL
YOU AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
HIM IN ANY WAY WE CAN THANKS
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURTNEY
JENSEN ON BEHALF OF TECHNO
AND -- WE -- BELIEVES THAT
HARNESSING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE THIS PARTY'S PERSONAL
CARRIERS ONE COURAGE PEOPLE
TO LEAVE IT LEAD HEALTHIER
AND MORE COMMUNITY BASED AND
SOCIALLY CONNECTED LIFESTYLES
AND CAN HELP ME CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS OF THE
FUTURE -- WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO LOOK AT THAT POLICIES
LIKE THE S. TO ADOPT SMART
AND ADAPTIVE AND LONG TERM
STRATEGIES THAT FOSTER
INNOVATION -- AND WE BELIEVE
AB THREE TWENTY SIX DOES JUST
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AUTHORS BILL
WITH THAT'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR BIGELOW
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
COUPLE QUESTIONS HERE --
FIRST ONE IS HAVE YOU DONE
THE CALCULATIONS ON WHAT THE
IMPACT WILL BE TO THE ELECTRIC
GRID -- AS AS THIS ISN'T
REALLY A TRUE ZERO EMISSION
IT DOES CREATE EMISSIONS TO
GENERATE ELECTRICITY AND AND
SO THERE WILL BE A DROP ON
THAT FACTOR AND THEN THERE
WILL BE A DRAW UPON THE THE
USE OF ELECTRICITY SO HAVE WE
DONE THE STUDIES TO SEE WHAT
THE IMPACTS WOULD BE CREATED
AS MORE THESE BECOME UTILIZED
YEAH MICHELIN OKAY -- ADDRESSING
THAT QUESTION BUT
SO THE THE STUDIES THAT WE'VE
DONE HAVE BEEN MOSTLY COMPARING
THIS TO ANY VEHICLE LIKE A CAR
TRIP OR OF A MOTORCYCLE OR
SCOOTER TRIP OR EVEN AN ELECTRIC
BICYCLE TRIP IN OUR ELECTRICITY
USAGE IS FAR LOWER THAN
ANY OF THOSE VEHICLES --
WE COULD GIVE YOU -- A SUM
TOTAL DRAW ON THE GREAT IT'S
IT'S VERY MINOR I MEAN THE
THE BATTERY PACK WE USE IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF ABOUT FOR A LAPTOP
COMPUTER BATTERIES AND WE HAVE
A RUN TIME OF AROUND FOUR AND
A HALF TO SIX HOURS DEPENDING
HOW QUICKLY YOU WALK SO IT'S
NOT A SUBSTANTIAL EXTRICITY'S
SURGE AND THE SECOND QUESTION
IS AS A PER UP IN PERSON IS
WALKING ACROSS REAL PEDESTRIAN
LIGHT I NOTICE THAT THERE'S AN
EXTENSION BETWEEN THE THE USER
AND THE WALKER AND OFTENTIMES
WE SEE PEOPLE CROSSING WHEN
THERE'S JUST A COUPLE OF
SECONDS LEFT THIS WILL BE A
LAG TIME AND IT WOULD PROBABLY
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO BE SEEN READILY -- BY
A MOTORIST WHO SOME YOU KNOW
GET READY TO TAKE OFF HAVE WE
ENCOUNTERED OR THOUGHT ABOUT HOW
TO ADDRESS THAT BY TIGHTENING
UP THE GREATEST I CAN ANSWER
-- THE THE G. TO ACTUALLY
HAS A DYNAMIC FOLLOWING DISTANCE
SO IT IS YOU GO SLOWER IT
GETS CLOSER TO YOU IN AS YOU
SPEED UP IT MOVES A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER AWAY NEVER MORE THAN
SIX FEET AWAY FROM A PERSON AT
ITS TOP SPEED WHICH FOR US IS
SIX AND A HALF MILES AN HOUR
SO THE EIGHT MILE AN HOUR IS
GREAT AND IT IT IS COVERED IN
LIGHTS AND THE LIGHTS ARE THERE
MORE FOR THE BYSTANDERS SO THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND IT'S MOVING
AND THE WHITES ACTUALLY MOVE
IN THE PATTERN OF MOVEMENT SO
YOU SEE HOW QUICKLY IT'S MOVING
-- SO WE THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
SAFER THAN BEING FOLLOWED BY A
PERSON -- WE ALSO FEEL TO
SAFER DEVICE THAN A BICYCLE OR
A DOG -- BECAUSE IT IT WEIGHS
LESS THAN IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH
SMARTER THAN TEN PERCENT ON
A ON A BIKE IN TERMS OF THE
MACHINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY FINAL QUESTION BIGELOW I'M
GOING TO INTERRUPT YOU ONE
SECOND HAVE A QUORUM PLACE
BUT CERTAINLY CALL THE ROLL
FRAZIER HERE FONG
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BIGELOW PRESENT TO
CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP FRIEDMAN
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON MEDINA
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN O'DONNELL
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM OF
MYSTICAL I APOLOGIZE NOT
AT ALL FINAL QUESTION
MISTER MAYOR CITY -- WITH
RESPECT TO THE BILL IT IT
IT DOES SEEM TO HAVE ABSENT
A COMPONENT THAT ADDRESSES
WOULD ADDRESS LOCAL CONTROL
SOME CITY SOME COUNTIES THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY TRUMP WE WOULD
ACTUALLY AT THE STATE LEVEL BE
AUTOMATICALLY TRUMPING THE LOCAL
CONTROL ASPECT BY SAYING IT'S BY
RIGHT ON THE WALKWAYS WHEN LOCAL
CITIES OR COUNTIES MAY WANT TO
NOT OR MAY WANT TO HAVE A WAY
TO REGULATE THAT HAVE YOU GIVEN
CONSIDERATION OF -- ADDING
SOME LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL
THAT WOULD MAKE THAT FLEXIBLE
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WE CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW ARE
ALWAYS -- OPEN TO WORKING WITH
OUR CITIES TO MAKING SURE THAT
-- THAT THEIR PARTICULAR
UNIQUE -- CONCERN SIR ARE
DRESSED BUT I I THINK THIS IS A
VERY BARE BONES -- -- BILL
-- THAT'S -- TALKING ABOUT
-- TRYING TO ESTABLISH SOME
MINIMUM STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR THE USE OF THESE DEVICES ON
SIDEWALKS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I MEAN THIS IS
NOT YOUR E. SCOOTER -- FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN THIS THIS --
-- THE THE THE THESE ARE LIKE
YOU KNOW THE MODERN VERSION
OF OF OF A LITTLE RED WAGON
THAT YOU BE BRINGING BEHIND
YOU YOU KNOW THAT -- I AND
AND AND SO WHILE I I CERTAINLY
RESPECT -- -- YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL
CONTROL IS ALWAYS TO --
RESPECTED AND SUPPORTED --
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE OPEN TO
-- ADDRESSING ANY CONCERNS --
-- IF THERE IS A NEED FOR ANY
PARTICULAR -- -- YOU KNOW
LOCAL CONTROL EXCEPTIONS TO BE
MADE BUT MR LYNN DO YOU HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS ON THAT OR
DO YOU THINK THAT COVERS IT NO I
THINK WE WANT TO BE AS PROACTIVE
AS POSSIBLE AND ASK PERMISSION
BEFORE WE DEPLOYED AND WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE OUR CUSTOMERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO USE IT IN A
LAWFUL FASHION BUT LEGISLATING
IN TOO MANY MUNICIPALITIES
IS REALLY A LITTLE BIT OF A
BURDEN FOR A COMPANY LIKE OURS
SO I JUST HAVE TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND WELL I I APPRECIATE
THAT RECOGNITION THAT YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK OF COURSE AND
HAVE AN OPEN MIND TO MAKING SURE
THE LOCALS STILL HAVE LITTLE
CONTROL THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
SINGLE SQUARE THERE'S
ISSUES LIKE CLOSENESS CHAIR I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN
WE'LL ALL BE USING THIS DEVICE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
FOR BRING YOUR BILL TO US TODAY
AS A PERSONAL MOBILITY DEVICES
CONTINUE TO HOPE PROLIFERATE
-- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE THE
STATE KEEP UP WITH THEM AND TO
FIND THEM APPROPRIATELY -- WITH
THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AMERICA SURVEY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER FONG
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN
BIGELOW Q.
CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP FRIEDMAN
GIPSON GRAYSON
MEDINA NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE BILL IS -- ON CALL
HELLO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- GONNA GO AHEAD
RIGHT NOW GO TO THE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND ANNOUNCEMENTS
MISSION MEASURES ON CONSENT OR
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
NINE FILE ITEM TEN FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX FILE ITEM ELEVEN A.
B. SIXTEEN FOURTEEN AND FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB EIGHTEEN
TEN -- DESERVE WHATEVER FIRST
AND SECOND PERSON SECONDS
MISTER BIGELOW MISTER FONG
-- MOST SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER FONG
CURRY BERMAN HELLO
TO CUNNINGHAM
DALY DEEP
FRIEDMAN GIPSON
GRAYSON MEDINA
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
IS THAT THAT IS NINE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE VERIFY
THAT WE HAD A FIRST AND A
SECOND ON MISTER MAYOR SO
SHE'S BILL PLEASE MR FONG
AND SCAN AFTER CHECK WITH
ME THAT WE DID WE HAVE THE
DO WE HAVE THE RECORD WHO
WAS THE FIRST OR SECOND WEEK
OKAY SO WE DID NOT HAVE THE
OKAY WE HAVE FIRST AND
SECOND THIS RECALL THE ROLE
I'M SORRY FOLKS WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WITH THE MOST THAT
WE HAVE THE ROLE THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER
HI FONG AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BIGELOW
CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DALY DEEP
FRIEDMAN GIPSON
GRAYSON MEDINA
IS THERE IN O'DONNELL
THAT IS IN A
DOES NOT LEAVE RULE CONTRACTS
MEMBERS AND AGAIN MR FUNG
THANK YOU FOR THE REMINDER
COMPARED TO FEDERAL PROCESSING
-- SHOULD PROMOTION DISTRIBUTORS
WE HAVE A FRONT MISTER FONG
MOTION FOR MISTER COOPER'S
BILL SECOND MISTER BIGELOW
-- MESSERVY CALL THE ROLL ON
-- AB ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES FRAZIER
FONG AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN BIGELOW
CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DALY DEEP ARE
FRIEDMAN GIPSON
GRAYSON MEDINA
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL
IT TOUCHES LÀ
TEN THAT AS FAMILY
ROLE CONTRAPTION
MEMBERS -- MISTER RAMOS
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE SIR
SEE WHERE YOU'RE AT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE CLARIFIES
DEFINITION A VESSEL OPERATOR
CLOSING A DANGEROUS LUPONE
ALLOWING THE LEGISLATURE TO HOLD
VESSEL OPERATORS -- ACCOUNTABLE
FOR DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR ON THE
STATE WATER WAYS THE HARBORS A
NAVIGATION CODE ALLOW SPECIFIED
MINERS TO OPERATE A VESSEL UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS IF THE MINOR
IS ACCOMPANIED BY AN ADULT WHO
IS AT LEAST EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
AGE AND WHO IS ATTENTIVE AND
SUPERVISING THE OPERATION OF THE
VESSEL THE COAST DEFINITION OF
OPERATOR IS THE PERSON ON BOARD
WHO IS STIRRING THE VESSEL WELL
UNDER WAY THE INTERPLAY OF
THESE TWO STATUES MEANS THAT THE
ADULT SUPERVISING THE MINOR WHO
WAS OPERATING THE VESSEL IS NOT
TECHNICALLY THE OPERATOR UNLESS
THE ADULT IS DURING THE VESSEL
THIS MEANS THAT RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR ON THE WATER WAYS
SUCH AS A LACK OF SUPERVISION
DRINKING OR OTHER DANGEROUS
BEHAVIOR CAN GO UNCHECKED DUE
TO LOOSE DEFINITION OF OPERATOR
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE SIX
TO CLARIFY THIS DEFINITION
TO ENSURE THE BEHAVIOR THAT
PUTS OTHER PEOPLE AT RISK
CAN AND WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE
IN DOING SO THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF OUR
WATER WAYS AND THE SECURITY
AND PEACE OF MIND FOR ALL THOSE
WHO ENJOY THEM WITH ME TODAY
THIS IS A MOOT TESSLER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL AND LIEUTENANT DAVID
COOK THE COMMANDER OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY'S MARINE SERVICE
UNIT AND CO CHAIR OF THE STATE
SHARES BOATING AND WATER CRAFT
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK ON OTHER
ON OUR WATER WAYS EVERY DAY
YEAH BUT WITNESSES TODAY
MYSTERON I HAVE WITNESSES HERE
RESEARCH IN NEW YORK AFTER
MINISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF
TO CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ARE PLEASED TO
BE THE SPONSORS OF AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE -- AND WE WANT TO
THANK SYMBOL MAIL RAMOS FOR --
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION -- AS
HE I MENTIONED WE DO HAVE THE
TEN AND DAVID COOK HERE WITH
US I'M FROM THE CONTRA COSTA
OFFICE OF SHERIFF WHO OVERSEES
ADD THESE OPERATIONS AND HE'S
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ON THE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE THANK YOU AND WE AT RICHARD
YOUR IPHONE ON THIS LEGISLATION
START
-- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
COME BEFORE YOU IN -- TEST
FRIDAY AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST FOR
AUTHORING THE BILL IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION FOR SPONSORING IT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- TO CLARIFY
-- SO RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE
HAVE ON THE WATER WAY TO BE SAFE
-- AND TO BE RESPONSIBLE WHEN
OPERATING VESSEL OR SUPERVISING
A MINOR ONE RESPONDED WHEN --
OPERATING VESSEL -- SO THAT --
-- WHEN -- A MINOR
IS OPERATING A VESSEL SOMEBODY
IS AVAILABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
AND ABLE TO TAKE CONTROL THE
VESSEL SOMETHING GOES WRONG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TEST FINDS FORTY AUTHORS BILL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO TESTIFY OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE MIST -- WILL
TAKE ME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
CAN QUESTIONS OF MR ALMOST
O'DONNELL YES SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS HERE SO AND AND I
THINK MAYBE THIS IS BETTER FOR
FOR FOR THE SHERIFF IF IF I
COULD -- SAID SO THE PURPOSE
OF THE BILL IS TO COULD YOU
JUST WALK ME THROUGH WHAT BUT
THE INTENT IS HERE YES SIR --
SO THE WAY LAW CURRENTLY READS
-- IN ORDER TO BE THE OPERATOR
OF A VESSEL -- THAT PERSON IS
THE PERSON WHO'S ACTUALLY IN
PHYSICAL CONTROL THE VOTE --
HOWEVER THE LAW DOES ALLOW FOR
-- A MINOR THE AGES OF TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN ILLEGALLY OPERATE A BOAT
AS LONG AS THAT PERSON IS UNDER
THE SUPERVISION OF A RESPONSIBLE
ADULT SO THE WAY LARA'S
RIGHT NOW IS A TWELVE YEAR OLD A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD CAN OPERATE THE
BOAT -- BUT THEY HAVE
TO BE UNDER SUPERVISION WITH
SOME OF THE THE SUIT THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES SUPERVISOR
CAN'T BE HELD RESPONSIBLE AS
THE OPERATOR IT IS SO THAT
TOLD A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD WOULD
NOT NEED A VOTERS LICENSE
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEY ARE THE
BILL UNDER THE CIVIL DISTRICT
IN YEAR OLD HAS TO BE UNDER
SUPERVISION BUT CURRENTLY DOES
NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE A BOATING
SAFETY CARD OKAY OKAY THAT'S
THE VOTING LICENSE THE NEW THING
IT'S SO YES SIR IT'S THE IT'S
THE RIGHT SAFETY IT'S A SAFETY
EDUCATOR HARDER OKAY -- SO THERE
ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE ON BOARD
OF ABOVE THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
WE WOULD BE THE VESSEL OWNER
TWO OR JUST ONLY THAT TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD GOT THE TERM
CONFUSE LIKE WHAT WHAT TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T COVER JUST EVER VOTE
RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE LAW READS
IF A BOAT IS A DRAFT WHICH MEANS
-- THE PERHAPS A SAILBOAT WHERE
THE -- THE PERSON WHO WOULD
BE THE OPERATOR OR MAYBE THE
ONLY PERSON ON BOARD GOES TO
WORK THE RATING -- OR CHANGE
SOME OTHER STATUS ON THE BOAT
THAT PERSON TO TECH TECHNICALLY
NOT THE OPERATOR BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THEIR HANDS ON
THE CONTROLS ABOUT BUT THEY'RE
THE ONLY PERSON THERE WHO'S
COULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
THE SAFE CONDUCT OF THE VOTE
SOME REALLY WITH THE TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD -- SOMEBODY HAS
TO BE RESPONSIBLE THERE SOBRE
AND ABLE TO TAKE CONTROL OF
THE VOTE IN CASE OF EMERGENCY
SO THIS BOAT DOES THIS VOTE
SPEAK TO SOBRIETY IN ANY IT'S
COVERED UNDER THE TENETS OF
THE BILL IS NOT NECESSARILY
DOESN'T IDENTIFY THE GOAL IS
TO DEFINE THE PERSON WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT MINOR AS
AN OPERATOR AND AS AN OPERATOR
THAT RESPONSIBILITY WAS OVER
SO IF I HAVE A BOAT AND I TURN
IT OVER TO ANOTHER PERSON TO TO
TO -- TO PILOT IN THIS PERSON
KNOWS HOW TO DRIVE A VOTE THIS
PERSON'S VOEPEL EXPERIENCE AND
THEY DO SOMETHING NEFARIOUS
WHEN MY BACK'S TURNED AND GET
INTO HARM'S WAY OR SOMETHING
THAT'S ILLEGAL WHAT I THE
OPERATORS TO BE HELD LIABLE
I GUESS THE KEY PIECE OF
INFORMATION SIR WOULD BE WHO
IS WHO IS A PERSON CURRENTLY
OPERATING ABOUT IS THAT PERSON
AUTHORIZED OPERABLE IF THEY'RE
TWELVE TO FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
THEY CAN'T THEY CAN'T BE THE
OPERATOR BECAUSE THEY CAN ONLY
OPERATE UNDER SUPERVISION THE
ONE THEY'RE NOT I MEAN THIS IS
THE ONLY SPEAK TO THAT TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN ONE NOW -- IN THE
CONTEXT AYE AS I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING YES SIR WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CREATE A
GREAT A LIABILITY TO THE OWNER
OF THE BOAT VERSUS SOMEBODY WHO
LEGALLY OPERATING ABOUT A PERSON
LEGALLY OPERATING ABOUT HAS A
VOTER CARD AND THAT PERSON IS
IN PHYSICAL CONTROL THEN THE
INVESTIGATION WOULD LEAN TO THAT
PERSON BEING THE OPERATIVE ABOUT
SO TOOK DOES THE BILL SPEAK TO
THE TWELVE TO FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
THAT'S WHERE HAVE USES COVER
EVERY AGE OR IS IT JUST AIMED AT
THE TWELVE TO FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
THE WHICH I BELIEVE AS THE LAW
WAS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THAT GAP ARE ALREADY
ALREADY CAPTURED THEY WOULD
THE OPERATOR THE BOAT THIS IS
A PERSON WHO HAS THEIR HANDS ON
CONTROL AS WELL WILL BE LABOR
THE POINT EITHER I'M JUST A
LITTLE CONFUSED ON WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO CAPTURE LISTEN I'M
SUPPORTER IF IT IS -- IT AND
I'M A VOTER AND I TURN MY VOTE
OVER TO TO PEOPLE MORE THAN
ONCE AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
TO BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE
SWIMMING YOU'VE GOT TO YOU
KNOW WAIT DOWN YOU'VE GOT TO GO
TEND TO THEM AND AND AND MAYBE
YOU'D THROAT NEUTRAL RUN BACK
OR MAYBE YOU GIVE YOU KNOW YOU
LET SOMEBODY ELSE PILOT VÀ SO I
SAID THAT'S WHY I'M CURIOUS IS
WHAT WHAT THIS REALLY CAPTURES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS SAYS THE
PERSON WHO IS AT LEAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE AND WHO WAS
ATTENTIVE AND SUPERVISING THE
OPERATION OF THE VESSEL BY A
PERSON TWELVE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
OR FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE PURSUANT
TO SPECIFY PROVISION OKAY SO
THE INTENT IS TO CAPTURE THAT
CERTAIN ADRIN IN ANY OKAY THANK
YOU AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO THE PERSONAL WATERCRAFT
ISSUES ON THE WATER I THINK IS
POSITIVE SO I HOPE THIS SPEAKS
TO THAT TOO BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THE REAL IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE
OUT THERE ON OUR WATER IS THAT
WHAT WE CALL SEEN THAT'S RIGHT
FLYING ALL OVER THE PLACE AND
AND OFTEN WITH KIDS AND THEY'RE
NOT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THESE DON'T HAVE BREAKS YOU'RE
ON THE WATER RIGHT SO -- OKAY
I THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
THANK YOU TO THE SPONSOR THANK
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE FROM
THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
SEEING NONE THIS AROMAS
WHICH REALLY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
--
THIS IS A BILL FOR TWO
DAYS THIS SEEMS LIKE AN
IMPORTANT CHANGE TO MAKE AN
ORDER FOR OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS SIGNALLERS ALSO
RECEIVE COME ALONG WITH US
OF THIS FOR YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE FONG
FONG I THANK YEAR CURRY
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
HELLO I Q. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DAILY DAILY
I DEEP DEEP I FRIEDMAN
GIPSON GRAYSON
MASON I MEDINA MEDINA
I IN THIS AREA JERRY AND I
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
THAT IS A LITTLE -- WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FRESA MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER ANDERSON THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR MISTER
NAZARIAN WILL
USE THIS TIME GET YOU
PREPARED -- AB FOR TEN PLEASE
SO WE NEED FOR COLD ON
NEXT OKAY
THE FRIEDMAN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FOR TEN WITH
THE FINAL MOTOR VEHICLE SITE
SHOW AND OUTLINED PENALTIES
FOR PARTICIPATION INCREASING
IN POPULARITY A SIDE SHOW
INVOLVES PARTICIPANTS SETTING
UP BLOCKADES ON A HIGHWAY OR
ROAD WITH DRIVERS ENGAGING IN
DANGEROUS DRIVING BEHAVIORS
INCLUDING RACING THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY DEGREE TIRE BURNOUTS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SPENDING
DONUTS AND OTHER RECKLESS
ACTIVITIES IN AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A SIDE
SHOW ON THE BAY BRIDGE SHUT
DOWN THE WESTBOUND LANES
AND CREATED MILES OF TRAFFIC
FOR DRIVERS HEADING INTO SAN
FRANCISCO EVEN WORSE MOTOR
VEHICLES A MOTOR VEHICLE SIDE
SHOW ACTIVITY HAS LED TO DEATH
JUST LAST YEAR A SIDE SHOW
IN OAKLAND RESULTED IN THREE
THAT'S WHEN A CAR COLLIDED
WITH SEVERAL PARKED CARS AND
A MAN WHO WAS WALKING ON THE
SIDEWALK THE PROLIFERATION
OF DANGEROUS STREET TAKEOVERS
FOR CAR STUNTS IN SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY THE GREATER SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY IS WAR SOME FOR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS JUST OUTSIDE MY
DISTRICT IN CHATSWORTH ASIDE
CHAU OCCURRED AT THE VERY OFTEN
BUSY INTERSECTION OF ME ST
AVENUE AND PLUMMER STREET WHERE
PARTICIPANTS HAD PUT UP CONES AT
EACH CORNER OF THE INTERSECTION
BLOCKING TRAFFIC AND TRAPPING
MOTORISTS ON EACH SIDE THIS BILL
WILL ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING
ONE CREATE A MECHANISM FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TRACK SITE
SHOWS AND A CLEAR PATH FOR
ENFORCEMENT TO OUTLINE PENALTIES
FOR PARTICIPATION INCLUDING
ORGANIZING THIS RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR THREE DETER SIDESHOW
ACTIVITIES FROM CONTINUING --
THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
INDIVIDUAL CRIMES AND A SIDE
SHOW IS THE ELEMENT OF BLOCKING
FREE MOVEMENT AND THE ROAD
TO OTHER PEOPLE IF A PERSON
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR BLOCKING
ACCESS TO TRAFFIC AND SOMEONE
DIES THERE SHOULD BE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES THE CONDUCT IN
A SIDE SHOW IS MORE THAN JUST
STREET RACING THE BUT RECKLESS
ACTIVITY WHERE INDIVIDUALS DON'T
COMPLY WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PUT LIVES AT RISK WITH ME
IN SUPPORT IS JONATHON FELDMAN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND BRANDON
APP FROM THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT BUT --
BEFORE THE OF MY WITNESSES
SPEAK MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW FOR
THE BRIEF VIDEO I WANTED ALL
THE MEMBERS -- -- TO ON
THE COMMITTEE TO GET A SENSE OF
WHAT THIS IS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
THIS IS NOT A GROUP OF KIDS JUST
HANGING OUT WHEN WE WERE GROWING
UP DOING GOOD FOR YOU A FEW
DOUGHNUTS SO PLEASE TAKE A LOOK
THIS IS SHERMAN I'M
A MOVE THE BILL SEC
NOW COLLEAGUES I'VE ALSO
SEEN FOOTAGE WHEN I WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED TO THIS ISSUE WHERE
BYSTANDERS WERE HIT AND THIS
IS WHAT'S CAUSED SEVERAL DEATHS
IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
PROFANITY THAT'S WHY WE'RE
JUST LEAVING THE AUDIBLE OUT
THIS IS ON A PUBLIC
INTERSECTION YES YES
THIS IS OUR NUMBER HERE THANK
YOU LIEUTENANT BRENDAN UP WITH
A LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF OUR DEPARTMENT --
WE'RE NO STRANGER TO THESE
THESE INSTANCE OF SIDESHOWS
IN FACT -- WE'VE HAD SOME
INSTANCE DOWN SOUTH THAT MADE
SOME SOME PRETTY -- NOTABLE
NEWS COVERAGE INCLUDING ONE
INCIDENT WHERE PEOPLE SHUT
DOWN THE ENTIRE ONE OH FIVE
FREEWAY -- JUST -- EAST OF THE
THE ONE TEN WHICH IS A MAJOR
MAJOR ARTERY DOWN SOUTH --
THE LA COUNTY FAIR FOR ITS BEEN
IN INVOLVED IN IN SIMILAR TYPES
LEGISLATION OVER THE YEARS WE
TRY TO SPONSOR A BILL SB TEN
SOME YEARS BACK THAT SOUGHT TO
-- MANDATE A MINIMUM IMPOUND
-- OF OF THIRTY DAYS AS WELL
AS REMOVING ANY ALTERATIONS
ILLEGAL MODIFICATIONS TO THE
THE VEHICLE TO REPLACE ON AND
THAT UNFORTUNATELY -- GOT TO
THE GOVERNOR AND AND WAS VETOED
WE'VE ALSO BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN'S BILL
I THINK WAS LAST YEAR THAT THAT
TOUCHED ON THE SAME TOPIC --
FOR THOSE REASONS -- IS THE LA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S FARM IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF -- ASSEMBLYMAN THE
SYRIANS BILL AND AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK SPEAKER
PLEASE CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHON
FELDMAN ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE ALSO SPONSORED BILLS ON
SIDE SHOWS OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS -- INDICATIVE OF THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM STATEWIDE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE FOR
HELP WITH TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE PENALTY SYSTEM THAT'S
IN PLACE FOR WHATEVER IT'S
WORTH IS NOT -- EFFECTIVELY
DETERRING THE BEHAVIOR YOU
KNOW WERE SEEN SIDE SHOWS --
PROMOTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA -- AS
-- MISTER NAZARIAN MENTION SIDE
SHOWS THAT HAVE RESULTED IN
DEATH OR GREAT BODILY HARM TO
THE BYSTANDERS AND PARTICIPANTS
IN AGAIN WE'RE ASKING FOR SOME
HELP IN ENSURING THESE DOWN AND
AND PROTECTING THE STREET SO WE
ASK WHERE I VOTE THANKS THANK
YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC STILL LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
-- TO THE AUTHORS BILL
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
WE REPRESENTING PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY
SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA WHO PARTICIPATE
INSIDE CHOSEN AND SPEED CONTESTS
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PENALTIES UNDER EXISTING LAW
WHERE SOMEONE INJURES OR KILLS
SOME SOMEONE IN THE COURSE OF
ONE OF THE SIDE SHOWS -- IN MOST
CASES FELONY PENALTIES WOULD
APPLY A SEVERE INCREASE IN THE
PENALTIES SUCH AS PROPOSED IN
EIGHTY FOUR TEN WILL DO NOTHING
TO DETER THE ACTIVITIES AND
QUESTION BEYOND WHAT IS ALREADY
IN EXISTING LAW AND WILL ONLY
RESULT IN LONGER JAIL AND
PRISON SENTENCES AT GREAT COST
TO THE STATE AND NO BENEFIT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY IN ADDITION I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
CRIMINALIZES A BROAD ARRAY OF
BEHAVIOR AS AIDING AND ABETTING
A SIDE SHOW INCLUDING ORGANIZING
FACILITATING ENCOURAGING OR
PROMOTING A SIDE SHOW THIS
COULD RESULT IN INDIVIDUALS
BEING PROSECUTED FOR SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS JUST BE SHARING
TO FACEBOOK POSTER TELLING SOME
FRIENDS ABOUT THE EVENT WE ARE
JOURNAL VOTE THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR MR GRAYSON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
DO WANNA THANK -- THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
-- IT IS A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
-- AND -- DEFINITELY A TRAFFIC
ISSUE AND AND I CAN SEE WHY
IT'S AN TRANSPORTATION -- I
JUST WANT TO STATE THAT --
I FULLY SUPPORTED FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION PERSPECTIVE --
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS THAT
I'D I HAVE AS WELL -- BUT I
DO UNDERSTAND THIS IS GOING
TO BE ALSO HEARD IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO BASED ON HOW THAT
THE COMMITTEE TURNS OUT AND
THE LANGUAGE AND HOW IT GETS
TIGHTENED UP A LITTLE BIT --
I LOOK FOR THE REMAINING AND
AND FULL SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS IT HOPEFULLY REACHES THE
FLOOR THANK YOU THE STRUGGLE
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TUNE
GOING TO BE VERY SUPPORTIVE I'VE
DRIVEN DOWN THE ONE TEN OR THE
ONE OH FIVE MORE THAN ONCE AND
SEEN CIRCLES AND YOU ALWAYS
WONDER WHAT TIME DID THAT
HAPPEN RIGHT AND I'VE SEEN
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY DO SHOW
YOUR CORRECTLY TO SHUT DOWN
THE FREEWAY AND THEN PUT ON THE
SHOW AND THEN GET OUT OF THERE
WITHIN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
I JUST THINK THERE ARE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES OF PARTS
OF THE BILL THAT I I HOPE YOU
DO -- ADDRESSES IT HEADS DOWN
THE PATH THANK YOU I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH ACLU AND SEE
WHAT MEDIUM WE CAN GET TO THAT
MAKES US BOTH A CONTENT
MISTER CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS ONE IF THE
SUPPORTERS OR THE AUTHOR
COULD ADDRESS THE ARGUMENTS
PUT FORWARD BY A SEAL YOU
SPECIFICALLY WHETHER EXISTING
LAWS LIKE RECKLESS DRIVING
EXHIBITION OF SPEED AND
THERE'S A THIRD ONE I THINK
THAT WAS CITED -- WHY THEY'RE
INADEQUATE TO COVER THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF CONDUCT
WE ASK THE US FOR
SILICON IF YOU'RE FOR STILL
HARBORS CONCERN I STILL THINK
THAT THERE ARE THE PUNISHMENT
IS IS STERN ENOUGH --
YOU CONDUCT A YOU
KNOW KIND OF SOMEWHAT CONTROL
THREE SIXTIES IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN INTERSECTION YOU INJURE
SOMEBODY AND THE MAX TIME
YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS YOU KNOW
SIX MONTHS -- WE JUST DON'T
THINK IT'S OF OF ENOUGH ENTER
A DETERRENT WE THINK JUST
AS TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
OOMPH BEHIND THE PUNISHMENT
THIS IS NOT THERE RIGHT NOW
THAT BUT AND ALSO I'D LIKE TO
ADD THAT THERE REALLY ISN'T
RIGHT NOW ANY SECTION IN THE
CODE THAT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES
THIS SO UNFORTUNATELY THIS ACT
GETS MISLABELLED MEAN FORGET
ABOUT THE PENALTY PORTION FOR
A MINUTE -- THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING THAT CITATION THAT
REALLY ACCURATELY DENOTES
THIS ACT AND HAS A COMMON
CODE SECTION NEXT TO IT TO
BE REFERENCED SO THAT WE CAN
ALSO COLLECT DATA TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
INCREASING OUR ACT
IS TO RIGHT NOW EVERY
JURISDICTION LABELS IT WHAT IT
SEIZE IT FIT SO IT'S CREATING
AN INCONSISTENCY AND IT'S LOSING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH OF A RISE
THERE IS IN THIS ACTIVITY
SO IF I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SOME COUNTIES OLES
SE PEOPLE FOR RECKLESS DRIVING
SOME WILL CITE THEM FOR TWENTY
THREE ONE ON AYE EXHIBITIONS BE
SOME SIGN FOR SOME OTHER THING
AND THE WRITTEN SO CONSEQUENTLY
THERE'S NO WAY TO GET A HANDLE
ON HOW WIDESPREAD THIS IS AND
AND MAYBE WHETHER THE EXISTING
LAWS ARE ADEQUATE FOR DETERRENCE
AND AND SUCH AS THAT YES
OKAY YES ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE
QUESTION IS THERE IS NOT CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AND
AND I DO KNOW I FULLY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE THE PENALTY
PORTION OF THIS AND I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON A GETTING
TO A PLACE WHERE ABOUT A WEEK
CONTINUE ADVANCING THIS BILL
-- BUT I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
PART OF ALSO THIS THE BRAZEN
THIS IN THIS HAPPENING THE
ORGANIZERS OF THIS FULLY KNOW
WELL WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
HOW THEY'RE CAUSING HARM WHEN
THEY USE THEIR VEHICLES TO
BLOCK TRAFFIC AND THEN TO USE
THAT OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO THROW
BOTTLES OR -- OTHER MATERIALS
AT POLICE VEHICLES --
THIS ACTUALLY HAS IF WE DON'T
TAKE STEPS RIGHT NOW TO REALLY
ADDRESS IT EFFECTIVELY I THINK
WE'RE ONLY GONNA SEE IT BECOME
WORSE OVER TIME SO -- WITH THAT
NIGHT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
FOR BRING THE BILL FOR THE --
THE DRIVING BEHAVIOR ITS SIZE
SHOWS IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
FOR BOTH THE PARTICIPATING AT
THOSE PARTICIPATING IN THEM AND
FOR THE SPECTATORS OFTENTIMES
THEY BECOME EVEN MORE DANGEROUS
AS WELL AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS SHOW UP AND AND
FLEE THE SCENE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE GIVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE NESTED
TO NECESSARY TOOLS TO STOP
UNSANCTIONED SHOWS THAT BEING
SAID MANY OF THE AXIS SUCH
SIDE SHOWS ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL
I HAVE SUPPORTED LEGISLATION
IN THE PAST TO ALLOW FOR THE
TOWING AND STORAGE OF VEHICLES
INCLUDE INVOLVED IN RECKLESS
DRIVING IN SPEED CONTESTS LIKE
FORTINO SEVEN BEFORE US TODAY
HOWEVER THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
IN THE CRIMINAL SANCTIONS IN THE
BILL OUR EXCESSIVE COMPARED
TO OTHER DRIVING OFFENSES
I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR URGING
OR I DO URGE YOU TO WORK WITH
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE A
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
AND THE ACLU AND HAVING
CRIMINAL FINES THE SENTENCES
MORE LINE WITH OTHER DRIVING
OFFENSES -- LIKES BECAUSE AS
OF RIGHT RECKLESS DRIVING BUT
I AGREE WITH YOU THERE HAS TO
BE A DETERRENT AND DOES HAVE TO
HURT SO THAT IT IS A DETERRENT
SO I THE BALANCE I HOPE YOU CAN
FIND THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL IT WE HAVE A FIRST BY --
-- SOMEWHERE DEEP INSIDE
A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG AT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY FRAZIER HI
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY NO
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I CHU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE DALY DALY AYE DEEP
I FRIEDMAN GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE IS ARIAN NAZARIAN
AYE O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I
GIPSON I
THAT IS THIRTEEN LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR APPS
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THIS ROAD ALL
YOU HAVE TO BILLS UP BY A
BEAST TWELVE SIXTY TWO AND
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE ARE YOU
MAYBE START WITH -- AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO FIVE
ORDERS SEC NUMBER SIX
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
EVERY STATE
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WHICH CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATES CAP AND TRADE
PROCEEDS FROM TO THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN TRUCK BUS AN OFF
ROAD VEHICLE EQUIPMENT AND
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AMOUNTS
FOR NEARLY FIFTY PERCENT
OF ALL ANNUAL GHG EMISSIONS
WITH A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THOSE EMISSIONS COMING
FROM FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION
DIESEL POWERED HEAVY DUTY
ENGINES FOR EXAMPLE ACCOUNT FOR
ONLY THREE PERCENT OF VEHICLES
ON CALIFORNIA ROADS BUT A
RESPONSIBLE FOR TWENTY THREE
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S ANNUAL
GHG EMISSIONS FRAZIER QUIT BUT
ALSO GENERATES A HIGH PORTION
OF AIR POLLUTION ACCOUNTING FOR
NEARLY HALF OF THE STATE WHY
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER AND
NITROGEN OXIDE EMISSIONS WHILE
THE STATE HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
TO ADDRESS TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR MISSIONS ACROSS MANY
PLATFORMS CLEARLY THERE'S STILL
MORE WORK TO DO THE CLEAN
TRUCK PROGRAM IS THE STATE'S
BEST PRIMERA VESTED TOOL TO
SUPPORT RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
AND DEPLOYMENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CLEAN VEHICLE AND
EQUIPMENT TECHNOLOGIES MULTI
-- FUND MULTI YEAR FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL
TO BRING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
TO MARKET THAT OFTEN TAKE
A SERIES OF INVESTMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATIONS NEED CERTAINTY
THAT PUBLIC SUPPORT WILL BE
AVAILABLE SEVERAL YEARS AHEAD
IN ORDER TO BETTER LEVERAGE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT ALLOCATING
MORE MONEY TO THE CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM ON A MULTI YEAR BASIS
WILL SEND A STRONG SIGNAL THE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS COMMITTED
TO TRANSFORMING OUR FREIGHT
SYSTEM AND MEETING OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS CORY BOWLES WITH
CAL START AND MATT ROMAN WITH
A CAN OF CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON CORBELS ON
BEHALF OF CAL STAR WE ARE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM FOCUSED ON --
DEPLOYING CLEAN VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES I'LL JUST SUM
UP AND SAY I THINK MISTER
O'DONNELL SAID IT BEST ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF -- OUR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS TO BRINGING THESE
NEW CLEAN VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
TO MARKET SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
PURCHASE THEM IN AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWELVE SIXTY TWO IS GOING
TO BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL I'M
TO ENSURING OUR CLEAN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING RENAISSANCE
-- ENCOURAGES -- BLOOMS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MATT ROOM OF CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION I'D JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT TO MEET THE STATE'S
EXISTING AMBITIOUS AIR QUALITY
IN CLIMATE GOALS THE GOODS
MOVEMENT INDUSTRY WILL NEED TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE -- TO
ADVANCE THAT STILL DEVELOPING
ZERO IN NEAR ZERO EMISSIONS
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE WITH HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THROUGH
LIKE THIS BEACON SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS WE WOULD
SHOW YOUR GRANT WE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN PROPANE
GAS ASSOCIATION AND THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY --
WE'RE PRETTY MUCH IN AN ERA
WHERE -- WE'RE FACING MULTI
YEAR MANDATES AND REQUIREMENTS
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
THOSE WITH AN ACTIVITY AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A SCENARIO
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE SENDS
A SIGNAL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET MULTI YEAR INCENTIVES SO
THERE'S A PREDICTABLE FLOW OF
FUNDS FOR US TO ACHIEVE THESE
VERY VERY AMBITIOUS GOALS WE
SUPPORT THANK USED THE STAGE
NAME ONLY REPRESENT PLEASE
MR TEAR MEMBERS RJ SAID ABOUT
THIS SOMEBODY HALF OF CISCO
AS WELL AS THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THIS CHEN MEMBERS MARIN BEEN
AT WHAT THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE AND WAREHOUSE UNION
WITH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR WE NEED OUT ALL THE
FUNDING THAT WE COULD GET OUT
THE PORTS TO MEET -- CARS GOALS
THAT IT'S UPON US THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT BRING A MEASURE FOR
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS ARE WRITING
CAN AB HALF OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST PROVIDER OF RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS TRANSMISSION FEEL
CLEAN ENERGY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
JUST SIGH YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THROUGH LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OR HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS BILL
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
THIS ROAD ONLY CHECK CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
-- HOBBY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE FREIGHT
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THEIR ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO FINANCE ADVANCED
HEAVY DUTY TECHNOLOGIES AND
PROVIDE A MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE FOR FREIGHT I THANK
YOU FOR THAT CURLY YOUR BILL
STILL KIND OF IN THE BARE BONES
STATE AND -- AS THAT YOU'RE
TRANSPORTATION I WOULD ALL BE
MONITORING CLOSELY TO HELP YOU
A MAKE SURE THE FREIGHT IS BEING
PRIORITIZED IN THE APPROPRIATE
FASHION A MATTER OF CERTAIN
SEE WE HAVE A FIRST WITH MR
GRAYSON SECOND MISTER GIBSON I
HAVE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THANK YOU THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE A
YEAR CURRY HI BERMAN
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE CHIU CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY DALY
AYE DEEP I FRIEDMAN
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON I AM MEDINA DENY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE
IT IS FORTY WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED WITH
THE AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
CARP TO ADOPT AS A HUNDRED
PERCENT ZERO CARBON STE ENERGY
CONTENT STANDARD FOR HYDROGEN
TRANSPORTATION FUEL BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST HYDROGEN
PRODUCING STATES IN THE NATION
ONE OF THE MOST PROMISING AND
RAPIDLY GROWING APPLICATIONS FOR
HYDROGEN IS ITS USE AS A
FUEL AS A FUEL TO POWER ZERO
EMISSIONS FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THE USE OF HIDING
VIRTUALLY ELIMINATES HEIGHT
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS OF CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND GREENHOUSE GASES
PRODUCING ONLY WATER AND HEAT
AS BY PRODUCTS WELL ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES PRODUCED NO
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS THE FUEL
WEATHER ELECTRICITY OR HYDRANT
CAN STILL BE HAVE CARBON
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH ITS
PRODUCTION BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
NEARLY FORTY TWO FORTY PERCENT
OF THE HYDROGEN DISPENSED FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES IN
CALIFORNIA WE GENERATED FROM LOW
CARBON SOURCES AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE SEEKS TO FURTHER REDUCE
THE CARBON INTENSITY OF HYDROGEN
FUELS BY EXPANDING CURRENT
ENVIRONMENTAL PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS FOR ITS USE IN
CALIFORNIA AND HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS JANE STEVENS WITH
FIRST ELEMENT FUEL MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THINK -- COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
A GREAT ANALYSIS WE SHOULD ALL
THE ALL THE WORK YOU GUYS PUT
INTO THAT -- I'M DOCTOR SHANE
STEPHENS ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
FIRST ELEMENT FUEL -- WE'RE A
SMALL CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY
-- HEADQUARTERED DOWN IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE FOUND IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND -- TODAY
WE ARE ACTUALLY THE LARGEST
RETAILER OF HYDROGEN FUEL
FOR FUEL CELL CARS -- THERE'S
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND -- FUEL
CELL CARS ON CALIFORNIA ROADS
TODAY SO THAT SITE NOT A HUGE
NUMBER EVEN OVER THE LARGEST
RETAILER -- BUT WE DID -- HELP
A SUCCESSFUL LAUNCH OF -- TOYOTA
HONDA AND HYUNDAI TO BRING --
COMMERCIAL FUEL CELL CARS INTO
THE CALIFORNIA MARKET PLACE AND
WE NOW SEE A RAPID GROWTH IN
BUT THE VEHICLE NUMBER IN THE
CONSUMER USAGE OF THOSE VEHICLES
-- OUR LITTLE COMPANY -- OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS HAVE HAVE
COMPLETED THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SUCCESSFUL FILLS A FUEL CELL
VEHICLES WE'VE ELIMINATED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION GASOLINE MILES AND
REPLACE THOSE WITH ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MILES AND WE'VE WAITED
OVER FORTY ONE MILLION POUNDS
OF CO TWO -- EMISSIONS IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT OUR VISION
WHEN WE STARTED THE COMPANY WAS
TO ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION
TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION AND
CLEAN INCLUDES OF COURSE THE
CARBONIZATION -- TODAY WE
DISPENSE A LITTLE OVER FORTY
PERCENT RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
FROM ARE HYDROGEN DISPENSERS
COLLECTIVELY -- AND THAT --
CUTS OUT ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
THE CARBON WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
LITTLE STICKER ON OUR DISPENSER
THAT SHOWS THAT WE DISPLAY IT
PROUDLY -- HOW WE COMPARE TO
GASOLINE MILES DRIVEN SO AS
ENVISIONED IN THIS BILL -- WE
BELIEVE WE CAN WORK WITH THE
-- AIRBOARD TO BUILD UPON THE
CURRENT THIRTY THREE PERCENT
RENEWABLE -- MANDATE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND CUT OUT
ALL OF THE CARBON FROM HYDROGEN
FUEL BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE --
CALIFORNIA POLICIES ARE LEADING
THE WORLD IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SIMILARLY
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS ARE LEADING
THE WORLD IN DEMANDING NOT ONLY
CLEAN VEHICLES BUT ALSO CLEAN
FUELS I GOT INTO THIS VEHICLE
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU GUYS IN THE
STATE'S ON BRING IT FORWARD
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY SO WHERE
THE AUTHORS BILL SIGNALED
HE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OR HAVE CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS
BILL SINGLES QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
THIS HOTEL IS EXIST AS RIVAL
THANK YOU MISTER HỌ DONALD --
MY HOPE THAT WE CAN CREATE A
FUTURE FOR HYDROGEN FUEL AND
HYDROGEN VEHICLES I REGION
TECHNOLOGIES CAN BE A VIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE AND LEGITIMATE
ALTERNATIVE SOURCE OF POWER
FOR VEHICLES IF DONE RIGHT
AND I HOPE I REALLY DO -- BUREAU
YOUR THEY THIS HELPS FACILITATE
YOUR GOAL -- MET SECRETARY
WE HAVE THE FIRST WITH MR
GIPSON SECOND BY MISTER CHIU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
FRAZIER HI FRAZIER AYE FONG
A YEAR CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE
CHU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALY AYE DEEP
FRIEDMAN GIPSON HEART
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I
THAT IS ELEVEN LEAVE
ROLLED IN FRANCE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MR BERMAN
WE PROCEEDING ON TO
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA
HAS AMBITIOUS CLIMATE NEAR
QUALITY GOALS ONE OF THE WAYS WE
PLAN TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS BUT
BEFORE THE POINT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ZERO MINUTE EMISSIONS
VEHICLES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AND FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY
THIRTY THIS WILL REQUIRE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PUBLIC
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS OF WHICH THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS JUST UNDER TWENTY
THOUSAND OR JUST EIGHTY PERCENT
OF WHAT WE NEED EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES THE PROVIDER OF ANY
V. CHARGING STATION TO ACCEPT
PAYMENT VIA CREDIT CARD OR
MOBILE TECHNOLOGY OR BOTH THIS
ENSURES OPEN ACCESS TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT MANDATING
ONE SPECIFIC TECHNOLOGY
HOWEVER THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS PROPOSED
A REGULATION WHICH WOULD
MANDATE ALL EXISTING AND FUTURE
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS TO BE
OUTFITTED WITH PHYSICAL CREDIT
CARD READERS WHILE I APPRECIATE
THE A ARBY'S WORK ON THIS ISSUE
THE REGULATION WOULD RESULT
IN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT ARE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
STATE'S EAGLES SPECIFICALLY
THIS REGULATION WOULD REQUIRE
EXISTING PUBLIC CHARGING
STATIONS TO BE RETROFITTED
REPLACED AT A COST OF SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHARGER
ACCORDING TO THE A. ARBY'S
ANALYSIS THIS WILL COST NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND TAKE VALUABLE
EXISTING CHARGING STATIONS
OUT OF OPERATION IT WOULD AT
LEAST DOUBLE THE COST OF FUTURE
CHARGING STATIONS AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WOULD PRESERVE
EXISTING LAW AND IS FOR OPEN
ACCESS TV CHARGING STATIONS
IT WOULD PROVIDE DRIVERS WITH
MULTIPLE PAYMENT OPTIONS WHILE
AVOIDING THE COSTLY SETBACKS
OF A CREDIT CARD READER
MANDATE AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES CHARGING STATIONS TO
BE EQUIPPED WITH A TOLL FREE
NUMBER FOR CREDIT CARD PAYMENTS
TAKEN OVER THE PHONE IN AT
LEAST TWO ADDITIONAL PAYMENT
METHODS INCLUDING OUR IF ID
CARDS MOBILE APPLICATIONS OF
VEHICLE TELEMATICS AND ONSITE
CAPACITY FOR CREDIT CARD PAYMENT
A PHYSICAL CREDIT CARD READER IS
AN OPTION BUT NOT A REQUIREMENT
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL SHOULD THE COMMITTEE
MOVE THIS BILL FOR TODAY WE
WILL CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO WORK TOWARD
A COMPROMISE THAT ADVANCES
ACCESS TO EVEN CHARGING STATIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE NINE
WITH ME TODAY I AFRAID NO WHERE
FROM THE SALON THAT LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND RICHARD SHORE SKI
FROM ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS FRED
NO WE'RE REPRESENTING THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY AND VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR TO ENSURE THAT ALL
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL MEET MODERN
PAYMENT REQUIREMENTS CALIFORNIA
HAS A GOAL AND THE LEADERSHIP
GROUP SUPPORTS THE DEPLOYMENT
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND FIVE MILLION
BY TWENTY THIRTY IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
DIVERT DEPLOYMENT GOAL TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PUBLIC EVEY CHARGING STATIONS
ARE NEEDED GIVE ME THIS CALL
AND ENABLE EVEY ADOPTION
CHARGING STATIONS ARE BEING
INSTALLED BY BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES ACROSS
THE STATE LARGELY IN MUNICIPAL
PARKING GARAGES RETAIL CENTERS
BUSINESSES UNIVERSITIES AND
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE INSTALLED
CHARGING STATIONS AND MANY OF
THEIR WORK PLACES THAT ARE USED
BY BOTH THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THE
PUBLIC THE AIR BE HAS ANNOUNCED
A PROPOSED RULE TO REQUIRE
ALL PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS
BE REMOVED AND REPLACED WITH
STATIONS THAT ARE OUTFITTED WITH
CREDIT CARD READERS OR FACE A
HEFTY FINE THIS WOULD CENTER
STATE BACK IN THE NUMBER OF
STATIONS DEPLOYED WHILE COSTING
BUSINESSES MONITOR DOLLARS TO
REPLACE PERFECTLY FUNCTIONING
STATIONS THE LEADERSHIP'S GROUP
SUPPORTS INNOVATION PAYMENT
METHODS AND TECHNOLOGY AND WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT DRIVERS ARE
ENCOURAGED TO CHARGE THEIR CARS
IN A CLEAN AND EFFICIENT WAY
FOR THIS REASON SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP SUPPORTS THIS
BILL WHICH UPDATES A LAW PASSED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN TO ENSURE
THE DRIVERS CAN NOW ACCESS
ALL PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS
THROUGH MULTIPLE PAYMENT OPTIONS
INCLUDING NEW TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
A CONTRACT LAST CREDIT CARDS
IN NEAR FIELD COMMUNICATION
ON A MOBILE DEVICE THE ARBY'S
PROPOSAL SETS THE STATE BACKED
THIS BILL WOULD MOVE THE STATE
FORD RAPIDLY BEER IN SUPPORT
AND WE WOULD RESPECT LATER
TONIGHT THANK YOU THANKS WHAT
IS PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RICHARD CHOI SKI ON
BEHALF OF THE U. V. CHARGING
ASSOCIATION THE V. CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IS COMPRISED OF
LEADING COMPANIES THAT DESIGN
MANUFACTURE INSTALL OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN EVEY CHARGING
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE HEADQUARTERED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT A DECADE OF FIELD AND
INNOVATION EXPERIENCE ACROSS
ALL THE VARIOUS SPECIALIZED
BUSINESSES AND USE CASES THAT
MAKE YOU BE CHARGING BETTER I
FIRST WANT UNDERSCORE THAT WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE A ARBY'S
WORK TODAY TO REALIZE THE
STATE'S CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
GOALS WE SHARE THEIR LONG TERM
VISION FOR DEPLOYING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND PROMOTING PUBLIC
ACCESS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
REFERENCED WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH HOW THIS REGULATION
WILL AFFECT CHARGING STATIONS
AND EVEY CHARGING SERVICES
WHETHER ALREADY DEPLOYED
OR IN THE CONTEXT OF FUTURE
INSTALLATIONS THE NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS INSTALLED IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY TOOK A DECADE
TO BUILD OUT STARTING FROM
SCRATCH WITH A COMBINATION OF
PRIVATE INVESTMENT STATE PAIR
STATE DOLLARS AND REPAIR FUNDS
THIS REGULATION AS PROPOSED
THREATENS TO WIPE OUT A LARGE
PROPORTION OF THIS INVESTMENT
AND IS LIKELY TO SLOW URGENTLY
NEEDED NEW PRIVATE INVESTMENT
AND THE STATE'S EVEY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE GIVEN THE SCOPE
AND THE NEED FOR CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT OUR
E. VEHICLES WE DO NOT THINK
THIS IS AN EFFICIENT USE OF
OUR LIMITED PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT DOLLARS TO ADD NEW
PAYMENT MECHANISMS WHEN EXISTING
MECHANISMS ARE JUST AS EFFECTIVE
FURTHER THE ADDED COST OF THE
PROPOSED PAYMENT MECHANISMS TO
FUTURE CHARGER INSTALLATIONS
CAN AMOUNT TO AS MUCH AS TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER CHARGER
INCLUDING BOTH THE HARDWARE
AND OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS AS CALCULATED BY THE A.
R. B. TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
THE AVERAGE LEVEL TWO CHARGING
STATION COST BETWEEN SIX HUNDRED
AND A THOUSAND DOLLARS CURRENTLY
NOT COUNTING INSTALLATION THIS
ADDED COST WILL UNDERMINE HOW
MUCH INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE
DEPLOYED GIVEN LIMITED DOLLARS
PAYMENT TECHNOLOGY TRENDS
ARE INCREASINGLY MOVING AWAY
FROM MAGNETIC STRIPE CREDIT
CARD READERS TO DIGITAL AND
CONTACTLESS FORMS OF PAYMENT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE MUCH MORE
RELIABLE AND SECURE THE EMBRACE
OF DIGITAL AND CONTACTLESS
PAYMENTS IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
CANADA AND EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
WHICH ARE NOT MANDATING CREDIT
CARD READERS FOR EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS MAGNETIC CARD READERS
FREQUENTLY MALFUNCTION THEY HAVE
HIGH MAINTENANCE COSTS AND ARE
LEADING SOURCE OF EVEY CHARGERS
GOING OFF LINE TO THE DETRIMENT
OF CONSUMERS LOOKING FOR A
RELIABLE CHARGING EXPERIENCE
AS AN INDUSTRY WE SURE THEY
ARBY'S GOAL FOR UNIVERSAL
CONVENIENT AND EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO CHARGING STATIONS WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THE MULTIPLE
PAYMENT MECHANISMS PROPOSED
IN AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
ARE CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
PAYMENT TRENDS AND GLOBAL BEST
PRACTICES IN TECHNOLOGY AND
REGULATION ALSO ME ALSO WITH
ME IS A BILL A CHECK QUIET WITH
VOLTA TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC STILL LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL PLEASE STEP FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR NAME IN HERE
REPRESENTING PLEASE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
AT THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT
AND SMART ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINT THE WORLD'S
LARGEST NETWORK OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS HERE IN SUPPORT
GRAY GARNER ON BEHALF OF TRIPLE
A NORTHERN CALIFORNIAN SUPPORT
CAME TO ME TO A TECHNICIAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO LIKE
TO TESTIFIED OPPOSITION -- OF
CONCERNS OF THE AUTHORS BILL
MISTER PORTER
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING PLEASE
MY NAME IS JEFFREY THE NUMBER
OF MISSING PLUG IN AMERICA
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN FRAZIER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
-- AND FIRST I WANTED TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND WELL
RESEARCHED ANALYSIS MY NAME IS
JAY FRIEDLAND AND I'M SENIOR
POLICY ADVISER FOR PLUG IN
AMERICA WHERE NONPROFIT --
ADVOCATING FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
DRIVERS I'M HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WHICH MIGHT BE CALLED THE
EEVEE LIMITED ACCESS ACT AND
IS AN ATTEMPT TO GUT SB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN
LET'S START UP WITH THE PREMISE
IMAGINE YOU PULL INTO A GAS
STATION AND YOU DIDN'T KNOW
IF IT WOULD TAKE YOUR CREDIT
CARD FOR PAYMENT AND THEN
IN ORDER TO PUMP YOU HAD TO
DOWNLOAD AN APP OR CALL ONE
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER OR JOIN A
CLUB TO FILL YOUR CAR SB
FOUR FIFTY FOUR WAS ORIGINALLY
CREATED TO MAKE SURE THIS THING
JUST DIDN'T HAPPEN AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR PROHIBITS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR CREDIT DEBIT
AND PREPAID CARDS LIKE THIS ONE
THAT WOULD BE SICKLY ALLOW
CARD READERS ARE THE MOST BASIC
WAY TO SOLVE THE ISSUE OF NEVER
LEAVING ANY DRIVERS STRANDED
AT A PUBLIC CHARGE THE BILL
CALLS FOR FUTURE TECHNOLOGIES
THEY'RE NOT YET AVAILABLE
INCLUDING CONTACTLESS CREDIT
CARDS IN VEHICLE TELEMATICS
CHARGING IS JUST WON'T WORK
ESPECIALLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUYING USED DVDS
WERE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE ARE ON BEING OR UNDER BAY
AND FOR THE TWENTY THREE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO DON'T YET
HAVE SMARTPHONES AND MANY MORE
WE CAN ALWAYS GET A SIGNAL A
SIMPLE SET OF FEAR REGULATIONS
WILL STRENGTHEN AND INCREASE
THE SIZE THE MARKET BY GIVING
DRIVERS THE CERTAINTY OF ACTUAL
OPEN ACCESS ESPECIALLY AS THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES GROWS AT
AN ACCELERATING PACE DON'T LET
SPECIAL INTERESTS HERE YOU SCARE
TACTICS THE BILL'S SPONSORS
WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THAT THE
COST TO ADD CARD READERS WILL
PLACE AN EXTREME BURDEN ON
THEM IN PREVIOUS INSTALLATIONS
WILL BE RIPPED OUT BUT THESE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN INFLATED OUT
OF PROPORTION AND THE COSTS
ARE LIKELY TO BE VERY MODEST
TAXPAYERS HAVE ALREADY PAID A
HUNDRED AND SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA TO THE SAME
CHARGING COMPANIES TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC TV INFRASTRUCTURE ISN'T
IT REASONABLE TO ASK THEM TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO EVERY DRIVER
IN SUMMARY WE BELIEVE THAT
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD ALLOW
THE REGULATORY PROCESS THAT IS
ALMOST COMPLETED TO FINISH AND
THEN CONSIDER TAKING UP THIS
BILL IF NECESSARY LET'S GIVE THE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE TO PURCHASE
AND DRIVE THESE VEHICLES THAT
WILL ENABLE THE RAPID EXPANSION
OF A FAIR AND OPEN MARKET FOR
PUBLIC TV CHARGING THANK YOU
THE STATION NAMES WE REPRESENT
PLEASE CHRIS CAME PERSIMMONS
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR SIEMENS HAS EIGHTY
TWO CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS THAT
INCLUDE MOST OF YOUR DISTRICTS
WE MANUFACTURE AND ASSEMBLE EVEY
CHARGERS IN CALIFORNIA USING
INCLUDING USING A MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESS SUBCONTRACTOR SEMEN
STRONGLY SUPPORTS UNIVERSAL
NON DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS TO
PUBLIC CHARGERS WHAT THE BILL
WOULD DO IS PERPETUATE A SYSTEM
OF CLOSED PROPRIETARY PAYMENT
TECHNOLOGIES CURRENTLY IN USE
THAT PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS
MANY OF WHICH WERE INSTALLED
USING PUBLIC FUNDS HOW FOCUSED
ON TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING THE
COSTS THAT WOULD RESULT FROM
AN ARBY'S DRAFT REGULATIONS
REQUIRING AN EMV CHIP CARD
READER THAT WOULD SUPPORT NOT
ONLY CREDIT AND DEBIT CARDS
BUT ALSO PREPAID CARDS MAKING
THOSE CHARGERS ACCESSIBLE TO ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
SOME CLAIM A CARD READERS
INSECURE AND WOULD INCREASE
FRAUD ON THE CONTRARY ACCORDING
TO MASTER CARD HIM THE CHIP
CARDS HAVE REDUCED FRAUD BY
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT MOREOVER
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF CHIP
CARDS FORTY PERCENT OF FRAUD A
SHIFTED ONLINE THE MASTER
CARD THERE IS NO OTHER PAYMENT
METHOD THAT IS SAFER FOR
CONSUMERS THAN EMV CHIP CARDS
SOME ALSO CONTEND THAT PHYSICAL
CARDS ARE BECOMING OBSOLETE
BUT ONLY SIXTEEN PERCENT OF
AMERICANS HAVE USED A DIGITAL
WALLET ACCORDING TO JP MORGAN
EVEN IN THE EUROPEAN UNION WHICH
IS A DECADE OR MORE AHEAD OF
THE U. S. THE ADOPTION RATES
ONLY FORTY FIVE PERCENT APPLE
JUST ANNOUNCED ITS OWN CREDIT
CARD NOW WHY WOULD THE WORLD'S
MOST INNOVATIVE COMPANY LAUNCH
A PRODUCT THAT SUPPOSEDLY
OBSOLETE HOLD TECHNOLOGY
FINALLY THE PROPONENTS CONTEND
IT'LL COST A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION TO RETROFIT CHARGERS
THIS IS THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
MORE CHARGES WOULD HAVE TO
BE RIPPED OUT AND REPLACED AT
AN ESTIMATED UNIT COST OF SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS HOWEVER USING
ACTUAL PUBLISHED DATA FOR LAST
YEAR THAT UNIT COSTS WOULD BE
ONLY NINETEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
MAKING THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
LESS THAN FORTY MILLION FOR NEW
CHARGERS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
TOTAL INSTALLED COSTS THE COST
INCREASE TO ENSURE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS YOUR CARD READERS WOULD
BE LESS THAN FOUR PERCENT
IN CONCLUSION I ASK YOU
HONORABLE MEMBERS WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME YOU HAD TO PROVIDE
YOUR PERSONAL INFORMATION THE
CHEVRON -- SHELL TO FILL YOUR
CAR WITH GAS THEN WHY SHOULD
CALIFORNIANS BE REQUIRED TO DO
THAT FOR CHARGING THEIR TV'S
WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO THANK
YOU OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE -- AUTHORS
BILL PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
WHO YOU REPRESENT PLEASE MARK
TAYLOR WITH THE GOLDEN GATE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SIX WITH THIS -- GARLAND
REPRESENTING GREEN LAUGHS --
WERE LEADING PROVIDER EVEY
CHARTING SOFTWARE AND SERVICES
-- WE'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN GROWING
MARKET FOR TRANSPORTATION
LITIGATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
IS INVOLVED IN CHARGING HIS
DENTURE DEPLOYMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE I'M HERE TODAY TO
COMMUNICATE OUR OPPOSITION THE
PRESENT FORM OF THIS BILL --
GREEN MUST TESTIFIED BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE SIX YEARS AGO
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FIVE
FOR WHICH THE INSTEAD PROPOSED
LEGISLATION WITH UNDERMINE EVERY
PLACE -- WELL THE REPROCESS
DEVELOPERS AND SLOW THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD LET PROCESS --
HAS A LOT ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
SAY THEIR PIECE AND -- ON THIS
ISSUE -- AS SUCH WE AGREE
WITH THE COMMITTEES -- ANALYSIS
THAT THIS BILL MAYBE THE
MATURE AND INDEED -- SUBMIT
THAT IT THAT IT ACTUALLY IS
RICHER SO FOR THESE REASONS --
WE -- DO NOT SUPPORTED IN ITS
CURRENT FORM AS IT SUPERSEDES
CARD ONGOING MILITARY PROCESS
AND AS SUCH GREEN NOT SO IT IS
-- DOES NOT SUPPORT THE BILL
IF YOU TAKE SPEAKER PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME WE REPRESENT
PLEASE HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CATHERINE GARCIA WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
A WE WERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR AND --
WITH THE CURRENT ITERATION OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR OUR MEMBERS
ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
PREMATURE AND CARP SHOULD
FIRST COMPLETE THE REGULATORY
PROCESS FOR THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE WHAT WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH OTHERS THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE TWITTER JUST COULDN'T
SAY THAT HI HANNIBAL
SMITH AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT WE WANTED TO
WEIGH IN AND SAY THAT WE THINK
THAT CONVERSATION THAT HAS
BEEN SPARKED BY THIS BILL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- THERE
NEEDS TO BE AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN REGULATION GOING
ON IT CARP AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT THE STATE'S FOCUS IS ON
ACHIEVING RAPID ACCELERATION
AND EXPANSION OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO METERS OF
GOALS WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL AT THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD PARTICULARLY FOR
EXISTING STATIONS -- SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
IN THIS PROCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU HERE THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FEEL LIKE TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS OF THE
BILL SEEM NONE QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
PART CARP HERE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CAR
NO WELL
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS THIS -- --
IN IN IN IN TERMS OF THIS
BILL MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
HAVE THESE CHARGING STATIONS
THAT REPAIRS AND TAXPAYERS PAY
TO PUT IN AND THEN NOW LET'S
CERTAIN KERR WAS ASKING FOR
THE REPLACEMENT OF THEM --
AT TAXPAYER COSTS SO CAN
IT THAT THAT'S MY THAT'S WHY
I'M SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'M
OF COURSE WOULD LIKE SOME
-- IF THEY'RE CHANGES THAT
COULD BE MADE TO TO TO --
TO MAKE THE OPPOSITION -- YOU
KNOW ME DOUBLE TO THAT TO TO
TO SUPPORTING THIS BILL IN THE
FUTURE I'M SUPPORT OF IT HI
MY VIEW IS THAT FROM A GOOD
GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT IN ITS TWO
IS THE TAX DOLLARS -- WE CAN BE
YOU KNOW HAVING USING TAX ARE
TO PUT IN CHARGING STATIONS AND
THEN USING TAX DOLLARS TO TAKE
HIM OUT THANK YOU ARE SOMEONE
OVER FONG AND I AGREE WITH
YOU A THOUSAND PERCENT THAT'S
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS WHY
I INTRODUCED THE BILL -- AND
-- WITH THE WAY THE CURRENT
CAR REGULATIONS ARE GOING IT
WOULD BE REQUIRED -- TO RIP
OUT ANY CHARGING STATIONS THAT
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE CREDIT
CARD -- A CREDIT CARD OPTION
IN THE THE COST OF THAT WAS
QUESTIONED BY THE OPPOSITION
BUT IT'S CARBS OWN NUMBERS THAT
STATE IT WOULD BE SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER CHARGER FOR A TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN WASTED TAXPAYER MONEY
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE RIPPED
OUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE A CREDIT CARD AND THE
REASON THEY DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
CREDIT CARDS EVEN THOUGH -- SB
-- -- WHAT IS IT FOR FIFTY
FOUR WAS MISREPRESENTED BY
THE OPPOSITION SB FOUR FIFTY
FOUR CLEARLY STATES THAT YOU
CAN HAVE A CREDIT CARD OR YOU
CAN HAVE A DIFFERENT PAYMENT
METHOD IT'S NOT AN AND IT'S IN
A WAR I THINK WE ALL KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A HAND IN A
WAR AND BECAUSE AS BEFORE FIFTY
FOUR HAD THAT THAT MEANS THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHARGING
STATIONS OUT THERE THAT DO NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A CREDIT CARD
PAYMENT METHOD -- AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S -- YOU KNOW WHY MY BILL
IS FRANKLY MORE ACCESSIBLE
THAN AB ARE THEN AS BEFORE
FIFTY FOUR WAS BUT ALL SIX MORE
THOSE COMING TO A CLOSE I AM I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER AND SAID
I'VE MET WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND I'M ON I'M SYMPATHETIC IN
TERMS OF MOVING FORWARD WITH
ANY NEW CHARGING STATIONS IF
IF THEY PROVIDE CREDIT CARD
OPTIONS ARE NOT -- HOPEFULLY
THAT IF THEY DO BOTH AND I'M OF
COURSE SUPPORT OF THAT BECAUSE
HE CERTAINLY -- IN THE CENTER
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE -- YEAH
MAYBE PEOPLE THAT NEED TO USE
THAT AND SO FOR ME IF THERE'S
SOME WAY THAT WE CAN DO WE CAN
MAKE CHANGES THE BILL -- THAT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD MAKE THE
BILL BETTER I'M OFF SUPPORT OF
IT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU BRIDGET YEAH THE OPPOSITION
SIDE WE HAVE SIXTY THREE OKAY
I'M SORRY HE WASN'T DIRECTLY
THE QUESTION DO YOU KNOW IF
YOU MUST ADDRESS A QUESTION TO
THE WITH MY APOLOGIES THANK YOU
BERMAN WAS LIKE CLOSE YEAH
-- YOU KNOW REALLY APPRECIATE
THE -- QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT WOULD BE CLEAR
ABOUT A COUPLE OF FACTS -- THE
OPTIONS LAID OUT A B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR OR STRONGER IN
TERMS OF ACCESSIBILITY IN
CONSUMER CHOICE AN EXISTING
LAW AND THE PROPOSED REGULATION
WE WANT TO MAKE A LECTURE
VEHICLES ACCESSIBLE TO FOLKS
IN ALL COMMUNITIES ACROSS ALL
INCOME LEVELS AND THE PAYMENT
STANDARDS UNDER AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR DO NOT REQUIRE
DRIVERS TO HAVE A SMARTPHONE TO
USE AND EASY CHARGING STATION
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND
THAT SMARTPHONE OWNERSHIP IS
MORE UBIQUITOUS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAN CREDIT CARD
OWNERSHIP IS SIXTY BURKE
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF ADULTS EARNING LESS THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OWN A
SMARTPHONE ACCORDING TO THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER AND ONLY SIXTY
PERCENT OF HOUSEHOLDS EARNING
LESS THAN FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON A CREDIT CARD ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL RESERVE DATA FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO CREDIT CARD READER
MANDATE WOULD NOT PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL COVERAGE FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES -- I ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF THE COST THAT WAS
RAISED EARLIER -- ALL TO SAY
THAT WE ALL WANT TO REACH OUR
STATE'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE GOALS
TAKING EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
OUT OF OPERATION TO BE REPLACED
IN ADDING COSTS IS NOT HOW WE
GET THERE AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL REDUCE UNNECESSARY
COSTS BARRIERS AND SHORE OPEN
ACCESS TO CHARGING STATIONS IN
ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRIC
VEHICLE GOALS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
ALL THIS FOR YOUR BILL TODAY
YOU KNOW THE -- WITH THE WRONG
AMOUNT OF CHARGING STATIONS
NOT ENOUGH YEAH HANDED LIKE
TO TAKE THAT OTHER HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
ACTUALLY CAPTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
WHEN WE HAVE THESE HUGE
MANDATES MOVING FORWARD AND
I'VE HAD CONSTITUENTS ACTUALLY
COMPLAIN TO ME THAT THEY'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO CHARGE BECAUSE
THERE'S TOO FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT ADVANCING
A TECHNOLOGY I DON'T WANNA
PUT PARAMETERS IN IN PLACE AND
ACTUALLY PREVENT US FROM MOVING
FORWARD I WOULD THINK THAT WE
WANT TO PUT THE CART BEHIND
THE HORSE AND ACTUALLY GET
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE BEFORE
WE HAVE ALL OF THESE CARS THAT
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF BUT ONLY
IF THEY CAN BE UTILIZED IN A
PRACTICAL FASHION WITH THAT
I KNOW THIS POLICY IS NOT
PERFECT I WANT YOU TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT WILL COME TO A COMPROMISE
OUR BALANCE BUT
RIGHT NOW EVERY TIME THAT THESE
AGENCIES PUT ANOTHER SEE OR
COST ON THE CONSUMER MAKES IT
FURTHER AND FURTHER UNATTAINABLE
THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
AND SECRETARY PLUS WE HAVE A
FIRST MISTER GRAYSON SECOND
WITH MISTER NAZARIAN --
MAPS OKAY PLEASE CALL THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRAZIER RAISE YOUR AYE FONG
FONG I THANK YEAR CURRY
HI BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CHU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
DALY AYE DEEP DEEP I
FRIEDMAN MAN I GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE MEDINA
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL LINE
IT IS THIRTY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN OF FRAPH SO MEMBERS BREAK
DO REALLY ASK YOU
TO WORK THE OPPOSITE ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
AB FORTINO SEVEN
PLEASE BECAUSE --
PROCEED WITH DIRECT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- SOME
OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS
BILL WILL LAST YEAR THIS IS
THE -- THE SAME BILL I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO BRING
IT BACK THIS YEAR A RECKLESS
DRIVING ILLEGAL STREET RACING
HAVE BEEN AN ONGOING PROBLEM IN
MY DISTRICT AND MOSTLY PROBABLY
IN YEARS AS WELL A DRIVERS
PUTTING THE PUBLIC IN HARM'S WAY
EVERY TIME THEY SPEED THROUGH A
NEIGHBORHOOD RACE ON INTERSTATE
OR PARTICIPATE IN A SIDE SHOW
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT IMPOUNDING VEHICLES HOUSTON
STREET RACING SERVES AS AN
ATTACK EFFECTIVE TOOL TO DEFER
TO DETER THE BEHAVIOR FOR TWO
REASONS IT'S COSTLY TO RETRIEVE
A VEHICLE FROM AND POUND AND IT
LIMITS THE DRIVER'S ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO RACE AND ANECDOTALLY
WHEN WE SPEAK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
MY OWN DISTRICT THEY SAY THAT
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
HAVE NO PROBLEM PAYING THE FINE
THEY'RE MAKING MONEY IN THE
STREET RACING THEY'RE MAKING
MONEY FROM THE SIDE SHOWS SO
PAYING A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FINE IS NOT AN ISSUE FOR THEM
BUT HAVING THEIR CAR IMPOUNDED
FOR THIRTY DAYS THAT'S A REAL
DETERRENT IN ADDITION THIS
BILL WILL BE THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE LAW WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ANY ILLEGAL MODIFICATIONS MADE
TO MAKE -- THESE VEHICLES --
INTO RACE RACE CARS INSTEAD OF
JUST REGULAR STREET CARS THIS
IS THE FIRST BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THOSE MODIFICATIONS
TO BE REMOVED BEFORE THE
CAR IS RETURNED TO ITS OWNER
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU GET A
CAR BACK TO CAN GO THREE TWO
MILES AN HOUR AND YOU KNOW
HOW IT IS ALL TRICKED OUT
YOU'RE JUST ASKING FOR TROUBLE
SECOND THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MS FREEMAN -- GIVE ME WITNESSES
OKAY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FEEL
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESOLUTION MUCH
LONG HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
GREG TURNER ON BEHALF
OF TRIPLE A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIAN SUPPORT ATTENTION
FOR THE AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
-- PLEASE STEP FORWARD
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN
THE REPRESENTING PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WITH REGARD TO IMPOUNDMENT THIS
BILL DOES ONE THING IT DID NUYS
JUDGES THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE
THEIR DISCRETION TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE LENGTH OF
EMPOWERMENT OF THE VEHICLE --
IF THE JUDGE FINDS IN A CASE
NOW -- FOR THESE CRIMES THAT
IMPOUNDMENT FOR THIRTY DAYS
IS THE BEST THE BEST LENGTH OF
TIME FOR IMPOUNDMENT THE JUDGE
CAN CAN DO THAT BUT THEY CAN
ALSO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE OFFENSE
AND THE OFFENDER AND DECIDE
THAT A LESSER IMPOUNDMENT
WILL SERVE THE PURPOSES --
OF OF THE COURT --
EMPOWERMENT OF THE VEHICLE
AND ESPECIALLY FOR AS LONG
AS THIRTY DAYS ALL TOO OFTEN
BECOMES A DE FACTO FORFEITURE
OF A VEHICLE AS MANY DEFENDANTS
ARE UNABLE TO PAY THE STORAGE
FEES CHARGED WHEN A VEHICLE
IS HELD FOR THAT LONG LOSS OF
A VEHICLE WHETHER FOR THIRTY
DAYS OR AS MAY BE THE CASE
PERMANENTLY CAN RESULT IN THE
DEFENDANT LOSING A JOB OR BEING
UNABLE TO FILL FELT FULFILL
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES -- WELL
THE BILL ALLOWS THE JUDGE SOME
DISCRETION WHEN EMPOWERMENT
WILL RESULT IN HARDSHIP FOR THE
FAMILY IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
JUDGE TO CONSIDER HARDSHIP TO
THE DEFENDANT OR WHETHER THE
DEFENDANT WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD
TO GET THE CAR BACK AFTER THIRTY
DAY IN TOWN THEN JUDGES SHOULD
RETAIN THE DISCRETION THEY HAVE
UNDER EXISTING LAW TO DETERMINE
THE APPROPRIATE PENALTY IN
EACH CASE INCLUDING WHETHER
AND FOR HOW LONG TO IMPOUND
THE VEHICLE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OR HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AUTHORS BILL ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR
THIS ARE YOUR CURRENT --
I LIKE YOUR BILL BECAUSE THE
FACT THAT ONCE YOU IMPOUND YOU
HAVE TO TAKE OFF ALL THE EXTRA
EQUIPMENT THE MAKES IT FASTER
AND I DON'T KNOW WHATEVER
IT DOES -- BUT I I THINK THAT
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD PIECE OF
IT THAT IT -- IMPOUNDS A BILL
WHEN IT GETS RETURNED YOU GOT
IT PRETTY MUCH STRIPPED DOWN TO
A FACTUAL ON MOBILE THANKS
THE THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SAID JUST TO CLARIFY THE
THE EXEMPTION FOR THE SECOND
RECKLESS DRIVING CONVICTION
WOULD BE LIMITED TO FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FOR THE FAMILY ON
UNDER THE THERE'S ACTUALLY
A WHOLE LIST OF EXEMPTIONS
THERE'S FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
THERE'S ALSO IF THE VEHICLE IS
-- PRIMARY VEHICLE USE FOR WORK
THERE SOME EXEMPTIONS THERE'S
EXEMPTIONS OF THE VEHICLE
WAS DRIVEN BY SOMEONE OTHER
THAN THE REGISTERED OWNER SO
IF YOUR CHILD TAKES THE CAR
SO THERE ARE OTHER SORT OF
OUTS FOR JUDGES TO CONSIDER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ISRAEL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST TO SAY THAT I DO APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS FROM THE ACLU WE
HAVE TRIED TO ADD EXEMPTIONS SO
THAT WE WOULD -- TRY TO PREVENT
THESE KINDS OF OF YOU KNOW AND
REASONABLE HARDSHIPS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME THIS IS A GROWING
PROBLEM AROUND THE STATE IT'S A
PROBLEM THAT LEADS THE LOSS OF
OF PEOPLE'S LIVES AND DRIVING
THE CAR IS A PRIVILEGE NOT A
RIGHT AND WHEN WE HAVE CHILDREN
BEING RUN DOWN IN INTERSECTIONS
IN LOS ANGELES WHEN WE HAVE
PEOPLE CONVICTED OF MISDEMEANOR
RECKLESS DRIVING WHICH IS NOT
ROLLING A STOP SIGN THIS IS
PEOPLE WHO ARE DRIVING WITH
A WANTON DISREGARD FOR OTHERS
IT'S ONE OF THE TOP CONCERNS
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD WE'VE HAD
-- YOU KNOW PEOPLE KILLED ON A
REGULAR BASIS IN GLENDALE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IT'S A
IT REALLY IS BECOME A CRISIS
AND YOU KNOW I SOMEBODY WHO
FREQUENTLY WALKS AND SIZE AND
CYCLES I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A REAL PENALTY IF
-- THEY ENGAGE IN THIS KIND OF
CRIMINAL ON THIS BEHAVIOR SO
I WITHOUT I WOULD URGE MY BOAT
THANK YOU THIS FRIEDMAN OF
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I KNOW YOU'VE WELL FOR
BEFORE -- VEHICLE IMPOUNDED
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE IN THE
AFFECT OF TOOLS TO DETERRING
REPEAT VIOLATIONS ALSO --
WE ALLOW FOR THE INCOME OF
THE VEHICLES UPON RECRUIT
ARRESTS FOR RECKLESS DRIVING
IS BECAUSE THIS IS SHOULD
ALSO ALLOWED UPON CONVICTION
-- I HAVE SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- AND CO AUTHORED
SIMILAR VERSIONS OF THIS BILL
AND -- THIS COMES AS COMMITTEE
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT AGAIN JUST KEEP GOING
DON'T GIVE UP WE HAVE THE
FIRST BY MR DAILY SECOND BY
MISTER DEEP -- MET SEVENTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER
HI FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE CHU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALY AYE DEEP
I FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON REASON I
MEDINA NOW I NECESSARY IN
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I
THANK YOU THAT IS THIRTEEN LEAD
ROLE PRESS MEMBERS THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN SO -- MADAM SECRETARY
WILL GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALLS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BERMAN BERMAN I Q.
I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE IN THIS AREA
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
FOURTEEN VOTES ON
ITEM ONE AB ONE TWENTY SIX
EMOTION IS DUE PASSED A
NATURAL RESOURCES AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN BERMAN I
CHIU CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN
NATURAL RESOURCES MIGHT NOT
OKAY GIPSON
ABSENT I THAT MEASURE
HAS FOURTEEN VOTES
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. THREE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN BERMAN
I CHIU CHU I DEEP
I'M SORRY FRIEDMAN
I FRIEDMAN GIPSON
HI GIPSON I NAZARIAN
THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN VOTES
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
FOR TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY IN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY FRIEDMAN
THAT MEASURE HAS THIRTEEN
EYES AND ONE NO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROWN MOST
EMOTIONS DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
CHIU CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON HI GIPSON
I THAT MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN
EYES ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
TWELVE SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON NATURAL RESOURCES FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN THAT MEASURE HAS
FOURTEEN EYES ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB FORTINO SEVEN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CUNNINGHAM
EIGHT FOURTEEN --
NAZARIAN THAT MEASURE
HAS THIRTEEN HIGHEST
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON GIPSON I
NAZARIAN THAT MEASURE HAS
FOURTEEN EYES ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS UP AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FIVE THE MOTIONS DO PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES FONG ANOTHER
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I
DEEP DEEP I FRIEDMAN
THAT MEASURE HAS THIRTEEN NICE
SO THE SERGEANTS SO TRY TO
CALL MISTER NAZARIAN ONE MORE
TIME WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
A FEW MINUTES JUST GET CUT IF
HE IS COMING BACK OR WEAKENED
TIMEFRAME PLEASE MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THAT IS RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN THIS AREA AND I THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS FIFTEEN VOTES ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE TWENTY
SIX MURATSUCHI THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
I THAT MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTES
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FORTINO
SEVEN BYE BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS NECESSARY IN
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN HI
THIS AREA AND I THAT
MEASURE HAS FOURTEEN I
ITEM NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
IN THIS AREA JERRY AND I
THAT MEASURE HAS FIFTEEN VOTES
THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN WITH THAT WILL
YEAH SO THAT WILL THE
COMPLETE THE BUSINESS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED